Actually, I did have another question.
I was looking through your staff page
and I was curious how you guys celebrate diversity
and inclusion within your team.
You know, Patrick,
that's a great question.
So we celebrate diversity in a lot of ways.
Um, as you can see in our south page,
it's something that
we're definitely still working on. But,
you know, um,
in may, we have a company Cinco de Mayo party
and we are really inclusive of the Hispanic community.
So that's something we look forward to every may.
Then it, of course,
you know, in June,
we celebrate Juneteenth for our
African American brothers and sisters because we here,
we do believe in black Lives matter.
Black lives matter here.
Absolutely. Then in,
then later in the year,
we celebrate Asian American Pacific Islander heritage.
Yes. And, um, during this time,
we actually took the stuff out to a Korean restaurant
and we had, um,
some Korean food. And yeah,
these are just some of the ways we celebrate diversity.
And yeah. Did you have any other questions though? Ah,
that I, I'm good.